I've struggled with ear infections for my whole life from seasonal allergies to poor
you station tube drainage. Since I've been an adult, I've mostly been able to keep them
under control naturally, however lately I've been struggling with what I think is a fungal ear
infection. I've been doing the rife programs for ear infection and ear conditions with which lists
ear fungus and swimmers or any other suggestions for this. Let me pull up a picture here because if I put
it over here and then let's put it on here. So that is your ear. So this is your outer ear,
your obviously, you got this is fat layer mode here. This is your
external ear canal. This here is your middle ear. I hope you can see by cursor. And the green here is
your inner part of your inner ear which is this is called your used station tube. So your station
tube is a soft vessel like tube. So it's like a vein except it doesn't like veins have
valves in it. The station tube doesn't have valves, but this will drain. This drains down to
down here which is your back of your throat. So the back of your throat was where your
station tube drains. And the purpose of the used station tube is to drain the middle ear. So this part
of the middle ear, if you have an infection, you'll have fluid build up in that and your used station tube
is to drain it. Now part of the reason why you have fluid build up in the middle ear is that when you
have an infection, the inflammation can block the used station tube. Or one could say part of the
reason why they have an infection is they have a blocked used station tube. Therefore fluid builds up
and you can get an infection. So what came first, the chicken or the egg, it doesn't make any
difference. So when a doctor looks in your ear with an otoscope, they'll see the ear drum here
bulged outward, bulged externally. And typically it could be discolored as well. So normally when you look
at the ear drum, you have a nice flat or actually concave ear drum with what's called this code of light
which it looks like a pearly white. That's a normal looking ear drum. If you have a middle ear
infection, it will be bulged out many times. It'll be more purpley, even red discolored, but you'll
have this bulge of the ear drum. Now the idea with children and putting tubes in the ear is they're
literally going and putting a teeny little three millimeter tube. They're putting a little hole in
the drum, putting a tube in there and that tube that drains the middle ear. The idea makes a lot of
sense because you got an infection in the middle ear. It's pushing that drum out and that's what causes
pain is that drum being pushed out. So the kid's got an ear pain, his ear hurt so much and the
drum is being pushed out because of a blockage in the use station tube. Now there's things that you
can do to help remove that blockage with the use in the use station tube. The rife will help that,
will help get flow. You could do the lymph program, lymph congestion program on your rife,
putting it right up by your ear. There is another physical technique, I wish I could show you
but if you put your finger in your mouth on the roof of your mouth and followed your finger all the way
back, you would elicit the gag reflex because you'll cause yourself to gag. But there is, if you went to
one side or the other, let's say it was my right ear that was causing the issues. I had a right ear
infection and if I looked in with an otoscope, I'd have a ball gene, externally ball gene,
ear drum. So there's obviously fluid in there. There's obviously blockage of that use station tube.
There's not getting the drainage down to the back of the throat because that's what the use station
tube drains right to the back of the throat. Now you could physically put your mouth on the roof,
put your finger on the roof of your mouth, follow it all the way back and then follow it back to one
side or the other. Now you will probably elicit the gag reflex so you have to do this really quick
and you will, there's there's a little indentation there where the use station tube comes out,
it's called the fossa of rosemielder. So if you could get your finger back to that fossa of
rosemielder and just wiggle your finger really quick and then pull your finger out before you throw up,
you could, it would stimulate this use station tube and possibly stimulate it to open up. I've done
this hundreds of times, a little kids and adults when I had a physical practice and that is
stimulating the where the use station to exits from the middle ear and drains from the middle
back to the fossa of rosemielder. Now the problem is you have to go really quick because you will
elicit a gag reflex, it's hard to do that on a kid because they'll bite your finger and blow a
mop and an adult you can get back there and tickle that and rub that to open that up. You can do other
things to try to open your use station tube, you know, you've tried to, you know, plug your nose and
blow really hard, there's all sorts of different things that you can do. All you're doing with plug
in your nose and blow it really hard or swallow it or gargling with salt water, you're trying to
stimulate that area, the fossa of rosemielder where the use station tube is exited and draining
the middle ear. So by stimulating it, you hope to have a reflex that opens that up.
That's what I would suggest. So doing all those things, trying to gargle with salt water,
you could gargle with an alcohol or something that could stimulate that and, you know,
trying to open that up. So that is a middle ear infection. That's very, very carbon. Could you have
a fungus in the middle ear? Maybe, what is it usually? All the studies that are out there? Like
literally 98% of the time, it's viral. So think of also on the right, writing the viral
complex program. That may help. Now don't confuse that. And it's completely different than having an
external ear infection. That's it. Infection in the canal here. And people can have very odd shaped
canals because the bones, their bones are different. So your canal is, is takes the shape of the boat.
If you have an extra large mastoid here, that could cause a very odd shaped canal and that could
cause a poolade so that a person has a little kind of indentation and poolade down here of the
external canal. And they're very prone to infections of the external canal. Now, infections
the external canal are different, totally different. It's on the external side of the ear drum. And that
is typically called swimmers ear because you get water in there and some people are more prone to
even going take it a shower because of that odd shaped canal. They can have more issues with the
external canal infections. That's a different issue. You're not really happy to do anything with
your station tube with that because the drum seals the external canal from the middle ear.
If you have a tear in the drum, you'll have loss of hearing for a period of time. No, the
drum will heal. But if you have a really bad middle ear infection, the drum could actually tear
hurt like the dickens, but then it doesn't give you relief because the fluid drains out the
canal external canal. But then it could take a while to heal and it could heal with a scar and you
could have hearing issues. You don't want to have to do that if it all possible. So if you have an
external canal issue, then putting garlic oil and olive oil, coconut oil can be helpful. Any oil
can help loosen things up and help with any infection in there. Even if you have a middle ear infection
using garlic oil, there is an herb farm brand of garlic oil that's made for the ear. It's external
garlic oil. It's garlic and olive oil. I think that you could put it there. And some garlic can
absorb through that, um, sympathetic memory, memory, the ear drum and get into there to help
fight infection. And then think of taking antivirals like garlic oil and and olive leaf extractor
things like that can be helpful as well.